Ever get the feeling you’re being watched?
If you’re out for a stroll on the farm, you might be right.
That’s because sheep
--and their sweet, wooly-faced
lambs
--have a secret.
Like us, these farm animals have specialized neurons
that focus on faces,
and they remember those faces for years.
Researchers think our brains process faces
not as collections of features,
but as integrated wholes--
for which we extract the information
from 2 or 3D representations.
To find out if sheep can recognize faces in this way,
researchers trained them to recognize photos
of celebrities
The sheep had to choose
between the celebrity and either a blank screen,
an object, or an unknown person.
All the sheep passed the test,
scoring an average of 80%,
showing that they learn to recognize unfamiliar faces,
even in 2-D.
But are sheep memorizing the images,
or do they recognize individuals?
In a second test, sheep had to choose
between a celebrity’s face
shown at a different angle and an unfamiliar person.
Humans can do this,
but our accuracy drops from about 90% to around
76.
Turns out, there was no pulling the wool
over these ovine eyes--
the sheep passed the test,
with a drop in performance similar to people.
That means that sheep,
like humans and other primates,
seem to have advanced face-recognition abilities,
something to keep in mind
the next time you come face-to-muzzle
with one of these gazing grazers.